I think everybody has their sort of unique characteristics.
And I think portraying that in an interview is talking about what brings you to that interview.
It's important for each candidate to leave me with what are the two or three or four things...
...that are truly unique about them.
But then, in addition to that, helping me understand how those two or three or four...
...unique things are relevant for Steward Health Care.
So, it's how are they different and how does that difference apply to the job at hand.
The idea that you have a sort of a mission, that you have a way of packaging,...
...what it is that you do is important.
There's nothing wrong with trying to build a construct around what you do,...
...it's just a personal "brand" to make it sound like you're gonna make a logo for yourself.
And that's probably a bit much.